all right so I'm especially excited for
this feed law because the heat is on
right now is gonna go off any second
it's gonna be crazy but till then I
guess we'll talk about the episode all
right so I'm wearing a tree trunks
button cuz I'm very Pro tree trunks
don't like this ass very anti tree trunk
shame on you because she is awesome
awesome if you like morons and I know
yeah I do
elephants tiny elephants that don't know
any better so I I think she's great but
okay so this episode she wakes up like
it looks like she was practically
beating or something it's just like this
horrific sadly there's stuff on the
ground and she just passed out cuz on so
this whole episode of them trying to go
around see what happens to be to the
apples and it went off and they try to
look where exactly like they could be
take and they get involved with this
whole like crime gangster thing that's
an to the apples means diamonds to them
and we find out Jake had this very
interesting backstory where he was like
this little hoodlum or something I
remember quite a few logs back you were
asking about Jake having a criminal past
you don't even remember that I get my
mouth shut no no it's actually really
funny and my favorite way he says you
know yeah I used to you know that's
where I used to store all my stolen
bikes you go and they still stolen bikes
there so I mean know better yeah I do
sort of like nice place you just signed
it no better it's okay
so they go on this little adventure
that's out of kind of pointless but kind
of funny to UM can like everything with
tree trunks pointless but funny thank
you know it's funny
um and they go to forget it so these
gangsters are gonna feed them to a pig
that's just like a normal sized pig that
has a very normal voice I joined of like
the pig the pig was fine I'm really
sorry I'll make it fast they're forcing
me to do this yeah I know I actually I'm
kinda hoping appears another episode
there's something I like about like the
normal everyday person sort of like in
the weird place but like they should be
weird too but they're not and just by
contrast I think they're really funny so
I just like how matter-of-fact it's just
like no yeah I hear apples
oh yeah over there whatever it there's
something about those characters in
really weird bizarre worlds I really
like and I'm hoping he comes back
obviously but I don't know if you will
so okay they got is so the apples it
turns out are in tree trunks closet I
love what she turns herself in she's
like crying I won't report a crime a
terrible crime and at first I think like
the police are like lady what what do
you do there in your house nowhere but
they actually come to arrest her which I
thought was really funny I love how she
walks it on force yet they still put the
cuffs I'm like her front legs or
whatever and it turns out through this
really complicated setup the crows are
going to Magpies are stealing the apples
take it out to a little nest on the roof
dropping it off and it falls into the
closet because these things never
apparently learn that they keep falling
into the closet and it's I like it too
that's not really all that complicated
you said it pretty darn fast and pretty
simple okay figuring it out
it's very cause even when Finn is like
wait a minute the Meg pipes
Randy princess in the ditch which is
crazy her back by the way oh yeah the
apples no scarecrow then being in the
closet I got it I was like I still don't
know what's leading to and then when you
see it it's like okay like I I could
never do that like it's so strange
and then tree trunks slaps one of their
butts and the end um I thought was funny
I I laugh every time I hear her voice I
love opiate I love how she's like she's
old and senile but she's still kind of
throws herself into everything in her
own sort of mellow a lie
Oh show you it's like she's she's so
into everything but she's also so slow I
think that's what I like I like that her
delivery so slow the way she moves uh
slow she's not very bright but she still
throws everything into it so that's
that's why I like treat drugs and that's
why I still think it's a good episode
counterpoint that's why you don't see
people like that on the walking dead
because it'll be dead
well if they're all our units I'm sorry
someone like that who is as slow as tree
trunks is as we saw by her first
appearance walking around what oh hi big
wall of flesh I'm gonna give you
stickers how do you not laughs just
saying that like I didn't but poor Finn
is consistently put in peril because of
her stupidity but she's gonna do nothing
oh she's like until she dies and then
finish gonna be all upset because she
couldn't save her she's got Vince gonna
die because of her and she said like
whatever I don't care I'm old and dumb
she's kind of like India Joseph's father
and Last Crusade it's like he's hungry
yeah it's like except even more useless
it's like Shawn Kyrie at least had a
back story and wrote the diary instead
she has like nothing which makes it even
funnier but she's like old and lovable
it's like no that old and lovable yeah
rusty and probably stinky I can't
explain it yeah you're kinda right I
shouldn't hate the cared to be no it's
like it's like that loving grab Kara
said the name of the women yeah it's
like that character it's like I should
hate this character really I should
anyone that just causally screams and is
the party pooper ruins everything is
that but there's just something about
the way they do it and I can't quite
explain it but it's just I think it's
really funny I think Lemongrab is funny
too so Oh for me Lemongrab is more kind
of like the character like he just
doesn't know any better I don't think
she knows any better she's old enough
where she should know better
no she's old enough where she shouldn't
because she's going nuts exactly that's
when you tossed him in a home but she
isn't all you said she's alone but she
does nothing no but she didn't know
no they come to her and they're gonna
have to come and visit be nice people
and they're not taking on this venture
hi okay but you know what it's probably
good pie I don't wanna argue that okay
I'll give you that
no okay one thing I want to bring up
because we're completely off subject
the episode was fine not a fan of tree
trunks but it was a fun episode I did
like the hole where they go into the
bathroom and tree trunks is so much of
an idiot she's eating the nasty toilet
paper like oh don't eat that
I like mom I like when you see Jay
covering himself in the bathroom in some
sort of brown goop really Oh No maybe
see the potted the pun yeah because I
did do a double-take on that one um but
yeah I mean I thought was fine you know
the adventure could probably be a little
more silly zany and goofy and big but
it's like you know like focus on tree
trunks
you know I it's probably not bad because
the last couple that we had were there
were so big and so zany as probably
everyone a little smaller like I said
I'm going back to that yeah especially
after the last episode of it makes sense
so no I like the character I I don't
feel it's gone to like lumpy Space
Princess yeah hurry yet where it's like
if my you never know they they still
keep a good balance with her just enough
where I think she's likable and I want
to see what what she's gonna say in
these certain situations where with
lumpy Space Princess a family okay I
think I'm done with you I think the big
problem was with LSP is that the entire
episode was her that's true she didn't
have anything to work off this one was
tree trunks
Finn and Jake and other people I won't
say this nothing different is it was
just tree trunks as she probably would
get on my nerves
no it's the interaction with the other
characters that's her baby sense yeah
it's it's her pond these giant
situations are really dangerous and her
not knowing any better going in thinking
like she's got control of it but she's I
don't know it's it's fine to me it's
like piggy in the brain there these two
little things they can't do anything but
they think
can take over the world in stem it just
makes me laugh except she can also make
pie and I like apple pie now one thing I
noticed that I don't know how many
people have noticed what was in the
basement when the worm run down to the
diamonds there's something in the
basement the head of a gumball Guardian
huh remember the gumball ghost the giant
oh wait are those the giant things that
are outside the castle yeah huh in that
basement is the head of a gumball
Guardian huh that's interesting
yeah the what's in there what is it
doing the other thing I noticed your
attitude now you're mentioning
background stuff is the in her closet
she has like this pinup guy like this
really built guy like a speedo
I just love how like just kind of a
horny old woman she is too hot she's
always he's my sexual wiles and I'm sexy
Oh aren't you an attractive it's just
she's so bizarre she just cracks me up
so I go from trying to bring up
something kind of important in the
background that may like shed light I go
to a small element being sexy
that is adventure time my friend this is
gone no never mind
done done done this is gone the creeps
that's what you're gonna say it wasn't
no no no I was gonna say it's gone from
bad to worse but that's not the next
episode that's the episode after the
creeps
ah that's good well I haven't done
segways in a while well that don't see
that cuz all the people are like trying
to find them in the video no no it was
this no down with that I think so so I
can stop yeah please please please good
cuz it was going from bad to worse